I got a chance to hang out with you and
henzo Gracie at ADCC he keeps messaging
me saying he's going to call me and not
calling me I think aside from being
hilarious charismatic and uh handsome
uh he is also uh and wise for his young
age
um he's also one of the greatest coaches
and athletes of all time in martial arts
so let me ask what have you learned
about life from Hansel Casey
the degree of difficulty
that henzo must have encountered he
never talked to us to us about it
because
uh but I figured this out as the years
went by the degree of difficulty that he
must have experienced when he first came
to Manhattan and started teaching it
must have just been incredible you've
got to remember henzo came from Brazil
training with
the best people in the world at that
time you know Hixson uh
all the machados all of them were
located
around Gracie Baja and
um
that Rio Rio de Janeiro set they all
knew each other and they all trained
together
they had internal problems of course and
but um uh they all knew each other well
and knew each other's games so they all
of them had beautiful and highly
developed Jiu Jitsu so all hens are new
from childhood on was perfect beautiful
Jiu Jitsu and communicating with other
people who also knew perfect beautiful
jiu-jitsu
then he comes to New York yeah where he
has to teach
in a language that he at that stage
barely spoke to a bunch of [ __ ]
morons who didn't even on my first day
in judicially they had to explain to me
the difference between the mount and the
guard because as far as I was concerned
hey you're on top it's the same thing
yeah and they're like no no mountain is
different from God and I'm like no it's
not like you're on top of the guy you
just hit him so he has to argue with you
and imagine going from training with
Hicks and Gracie to having to tell some
[ __ ]
that God is different from Mount and we
was we were so primitive back then
he went from the best training culture
in the world to literally the worst just
a bunch of
guys in their mid-20s who knew nothing
about the ground
just well luckily he's known my first
patience
but out of that he molded one of the
greatest gyms ever in New York yes uh he
had uh he did a fantastic job and most
of it was based around the idea that he
gave us complete Freedom we came in we
trained all day and I started teaching
beginner's classes
um and then some of his senior students
uh hikarua made a Rodrigo Gracie and
Matt Sarah opened their own schools
around the tri-state area so they left
there was a vacuum of teachers and he
asked me to start teaching
um uh I taught for for many many years
there and he always gave us complete
Freedom his only thing was to say okay
do whatever you want just make sure it's
effective prove to me it's effective and
that's the best research program you can
ever get you know show me proof and um
uh the you know so many times especially
in those days in Jiu Jitsu there were so
many things that were just off limits
like you couldn't study leg loss you
couldn't do this you couldn't do that
like this kind of game was for cowards
this kind of this is the only kind of
game we accept and Enzo was never like
that he was just like okay just do what
you want prove to me it works and if you
give people
that simple structure you give them some
time some Ingenuity a lot of things can
happen I gotta ask you and by the way
he'll come on this podcast and I do feel
like it's a little bit like riding a
dragon or a bull of some kind it'll be
it'll be a fun Journey there's I can't
at least from my perspective
uh having interacting or having met him
it's hard not to smile
um for me he's easily one of the most
charismatic people in Judaism it's kind
of a fun to watch that humans can be
like this too it's just the the love
that radiates from him is incredible